I served from October 1982 to November 2002.
I served from 2005 to 2009.
From June 2010 to December 2013.
I served from 1989 until 2011.
I served from 1991 to today, and I will always
remember my oath.
I will always remember my oath.
I will always remember my oath, always remember
my oath.
I will always remember my oath.
I, Jon Lewis, I, Mike Harner, I, Hannah Zeiser,
I, Michael Murray, I, Bruce Leon Wykes do
solemnly swear that I will support and defend,
that I will support and defend the Constitution
of the United States against all enemies,
foreign and domestic; that I will bear true
faith and allegiance to the same; that I take
this obligation freely, and without mental
reservation or purpose of evasion, and that
I will obey the orders of the President of
the United States and the orders of the officers
appointed over me, according to regulations
and the Uniform Code of the Military Justice.
And that I will well and faithfully discharge
the duties of the office on which I am about
to enter, duties of the office on which I
am about to enter.
So help me God.